نكمل حلقتنا مع خبر تاني متعلق بالون ماسك
في الملياردير اخباره اليوم مو بس متعلقه
بالسياسه والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بل
كمان بموضوع ملح وكثر الحديث عنه مؤخرا
وصاير طبعا عنوان اساسي معانا طبعا نحن
بنتكلم هنا عن الذكاء الاصطناعي فقال من
اوائل الناس اللي استثمروا في الذكاء
الاصطناعي ورجع لاحقا اعرب عن ندم وعلى
الموضوع وصار من قاده المعسكر اللي بيدعو
لتخفيف استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وتقنين
الموضوع ويحذر من خطورته وفي مقابله مع سي
ان بي سي من كم يوم جددت موقفه
من الذكاء الاصطناعي وبس لكن كمان اعرب عن
ندم الشديد عند فيما يتعلق تحديدا في
استثمارات السابقه في شركات الذكاء
الاصطناعي نحن بنتكلم هنا ترى عن تحديدا
open
صاحب فكره الاسم اصلا وانه لولا اصلا ما
كان حيكون في شركه اوبن اي اي وقال انه
اسسها لانه جوجل كانت مسيطره على سوق
الذكاء الاصطناعي تماما لكن اعترف كمان
انه قلل بينه وبين نفسه بدايه من open اي
وانه كان احمق كبير لما نستخب فيها ماسك
من مؤسسي الشركه وتركها في 2018 بسبب
خلافات مع المؤسسين التنين طيب بعدها
بسناء الشركه اللي بدات غير ربحيه تحولت
لي ربحيه ماسك وجه سهام في تصريحاته كمان
لاحد مؤسسي جوجل اللي قال انه حضره مرارا
من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي على البشريه
لكن مؤسس جوجل ما كان فارق معاه
انا المسكو مؤسس جوجل كانوا اعز اصحاب
بحسب كلام ماسكو خسروا بعضهم بسبب خلافهم
في وجهات النظر بخصوص الذكاء الاصطناعي
تصريحات ايلون ماسك عن اوبن اي اي فتح
فيها جبهه صراع ثانيه بينه وبين
مايكروسوفت حذر من التحكم الاكبر
للمايكروسوفت في الاوبن اي اليوم وقال انه
الموضوع اكبر مما يظن قاده الشركه
مايكروسوفت ما استقبلت التصريحات بهدوء
ابدا وطلع رئيسها وقال انه شركته ما
بتسيطر على اوبن اي اي كما يدعي ماسك
للعلم مايكروسوفت بدات الاستثمار في اوبن
اي اي 2019 وللان حجم استثماراتها
التراكميه في الشركه 13 مليار دولار